welcome to this video playing match p
match p jung plate him twice one draw
one loss that's not great but now at
least get the maroc see point where i
have a pretty good score this is a very
rare line nowadays is Nyjah find
especially then going back to 12 c 6
sunset at somewhat passive um it's not a
not stare it's not terrible it's just a
little bit for modern standards as a
little bit it's a little bit passive
okay so also be six not not ecstatic
specially especially ambitious okay f3
or h 4f for many ideas I've form a for
Nyjah form that's actually interesting
because I can maybe em put this Bishop
offside take stakes f5 okay he's not
doing that at all and f5 mmm yeah that's
that's debatable really if f5 is a moose
okay it's interesting it's probably
nothing maybe not the best move but it
is interesting and now something like
this maybe or doubling on the FL maybe
double on the F file
so yeah well the e5 Knight is quite a
good defender or passive Bishop to h6
this is something at all or is this like
totally ridiculous way it's not totally
ridiculous but but close to that later
f6 might be might be on a sharp-eyed
Rugal f 4 h for this is this kind of
business but okay I don't think it's so
great for him to take on on age 60 I can
go from here and f six maybe more yeah
it's the counter play but it is it as a
pawn me you know I've start with this
and then grab the pawn it's really can
really just take it yeah but have things
like Bishop c6 I have thought that might
be interesting or some other ideas
and also this is f six idea f6 takes
root chicks look 25 yeah it's not so bad
really it's not bad
you can also just protected here it
looks better but if he's not taking this
pawn what exactly is the idea of this
whole procedure queena form
one day they should play of six or not
this is also possible
yeah you know but I should have done I
should have played exactly what I did
just quick out check check so he's got
some possible ideas with 94 and stuff
like that so let's cover that King age 2
is my next move I think okay can go
whoopsie tool I can take it and King
edge to write check yes but what what is
the threat not sure what the thread is
Nyjah for is not threatened malukas
protected Queen D 1 ok whatever it is
I'm trying for for Bishop II aid now oh
yes rooks his son maybe he really owned
everybody just has Roxy 7 and I that I
didn't seem very simple stuff Oh time
morning yes okay i didn't i didn't think
about this simple captcha on d5
points are still some more dangerous
queen is seven or is this stupid my
position is somewhat somewhat shaky
somewhat shake him p 5 a 6 or the next
move it's not so easy famous valya f7 is
always attacked of course
don't really see a move I'm this is this
is what comes to mind for Queen g3 check
at the end sets b6 and the pawns promote
that was necessary the only way to win i
think and i hope i'm really winning not
screwing this up a very tricky very
tricky position I don't think I wasn't
in in great shape at some point it
looked would look wrong check
check-check
black reserve okay to hey silenced the
phone ok yeah this is this is an
interesting int really interesting
position where the humanists really
helpless compared to the computer jack
sure the engine is just saying why twins
totally yeah with a five I didn't really
see that the Queen takes hundreds I it
fits very simple I thought something
like oopsy seven but ok he took and a
five and wide winds here I mean so it
feels so I was a winning yeah all the
time it didn't feel like that I really
felt that I have have problems b 5h 4b
six he and Bishop SI Mia played all the
composer looks like cheating tell
sometimes sometimes you really managed
to jump to play play okay am I really
thought I did something wrong because it
felt like big count of jack but maybe
this is really not the case yeah look do
you one just protecting and before this
it is strong you playing all the combos
so this was maybe not that bad i really
felt that I I allowed things him ok well
nice thing at the end of this with those
two pawns thanks for watching